the brain can really control what's
going on in the body even in rather
extreme circumstances what comes to mind
when I say the word hypnosis if it's
spinning pinwheels or swaying pocket
watches then you're not alone but
clinical hypnosis what today's guest
calls transformation
t-r-a-n-c-e is no parlor trick people
worry hypnosis means losing control it
doesn't it means in enhancing control of
your brain and of your experience it is
a very real and efficacious therapeutic
protocol that induces a unique brain
state that can be leveraged to improve
quite quickly I might add everything
from sleep states to high performance it
can be a tool Against Addiction and a
very effective means to ameliorate
symptoms related to trauma anxiety
chronic pain and more that's what
hypnosis is it's a naturally occurring
experience it doesn't just happen when I
dangle a watch it's a state of Highly
focused attention with reduced
peripheral awareness my guess for this
exploration is the world's leading
researcher and clinician in the field of
hypnosis Dr David Spiegel Dr Spiegel is
the associate chair of Psychiatry and
Behavioral Sciences at Stanford
University of school of medicine Dr
Spiegel has published over 480 Journal
articles and 13 books like I said he's a
World expert and he's here today to
share the science and the neurobiology
behind hypnosis meaning what exactly
transpires in the brain during a
hypnotic State as well as the many
efficacious use cases for it the main
treatment for PTSD is not to have them
avoid and run away from it it's to have
them face it in a controlled supportive
thoughtful way that's the only way we
humans are going to survive we have to
face our own vulnerabilities we talk
about the differences between hypnosis
mindfulness visualization and so-called
flow States we discuss why some people
are more hypnotizable than others and
the mind-body connection incident to
hypnosis finally Dr Spiegel imparts
helpful tools for self-hypnosis
including a simple test to gauge your
own receptivity to hypnosis as well as
reference to the reverie mobile app
which is a tool that was developed by Dr
Spiegel and his lab at Stanford the app
does have a nominal cost but Dr Spiegel
and his team were kind enough to offer
all of you a special discount on the
reverie service which you should see
right here on the screen and also in the
description below and in the show notes
on the episode page at rushroll.com I
should add that I received no benefit
from this offer it's simply a gift to
you for observing this video and perhaps
a nudge check it out and with that do me
a favor please hit that subscribe button
and enjoy what I think you will find to
be a truly fascinating conversation with
Dr David Spiegel
well David it's a it's a delight to meet
you I appreciate our mutual friend Dr
Andrew huberman introducing us uh I'm
really excited to talk to you today
before we get into anything though I
think it's important to point out uh one
specific thing for clarity purposes
which is that you are not the
psychiatrist David Spiegel who testified
for Amber Heard in the Johnny Depp trial
correct
correct your honor
I'm I'm uh I can't help but ask uh were
were you confused with him did you end
up you know on the receiving end of some
nasty threats and such I I um so far not
nasty threats I did my my star rating
went down temporarily at Stanford
because some people pretended that they
had seen me clinically and gave me a
terrible rating
um I was having dinner was we invited
some friends over and this one of my
friends a very bright woman who says
what she thinks she said now David you
told me that psychiatrists cannot make
render opinions about people they have
not examined and yet today you testified
in court
about him and about his you know how he
must have done it because he played a
pirate somewhere you know and I said I
did not and I should so then she showed
me the video and it was the first that I
knew of it I didn't know this guy
existed David R Spiel I don't have a
middle name so I'm not David R
and then there have been a couple of
things
um uh on the on you know in the uh
social media space about how apparently
her lawyer got advice to hire me and
um looked up David Spiegel and found
this guy who was in Eastern Virginia
medical school and she thought oh well
he's nearby won't cost much you know
I'll just get him to do it that's great
wow the plot thickens so you were
actually meant to be the person that's I
don't know that for sure I was never
called I was never contacted but
um apparently several people had got
information that the lawyer who made who
mentioned the name called her up
afterwards and said I told you David
Spiegel from Stanford
and she said oh [ __ ] you know this is
bad news wow well you dodged a bullet
not that you would have agreed to do
that in the first place but
um yeah it was a very interesting kind
of social phenomenon the manner in which
you know social media bifurcated over
that case and armies of people lined up
to defend and attack yeah yeah and you
happen to be kind of uh collateral
damage to some extent well you know I
got two kinds of emails one kind said I
couldn't possibly be you I know you I
know what your work is like I know your
research it could that could not you
could not have been the David Spiegel
and so thanks well a simple sorry to
interject a simple cursory Google search
you could see the guy there's video in
him right now it's easily discernible
and I got a couple other emails saying
good for you you said exactly what
should have been said congratulations I
thought okay yeah well that's like a uh
you know a psychological experiment unto
itself it is this it is yeah you know
the I mean we're learning a lot about
how people can affiliate with false
beliefs of various kinds so yeah well
there's a there's a meta conversation to
be had around that for sure you bet um
perhaps for another day because today
we're going to focus on hypnosis the
myths the truce the science
um and so I think it's important just
out of the gate to Define what it is we
mean when we say hypnosis the difference
between stage hypnosis clinical hypnosis
and and perhaps provide kind of a
cursory glance at your research and
clinical work sure I'd be happy to do
that
um if you've ever gotten so caught up in
a good movie that you forget you're
watching a movie you enter the Imagine
world you're part of the film not the
audience that's a hypnotic like State
it's a state of Highly focused attention
with reduced peripheral awareness so in
order to really engage fully you have to
decide you're not going to be worried
about what you're have to do later in
the day you're not going to pay
attention to anything else you're going
to narrow your focus and that has a
couple of consequences it lets you think
very clearly very well
it also gives you a kind of cognitive
flexibility that used to be called
suggestibility you know and people worry
about that you know can you make me
think I'm a chicken and do all kinds of
foolish things
and
um it that but that also means you're
willing to approach uh an Old Situation
from a new point of view to see it
differently if you intensely Focus if
you suspend judgment
you can learn and so it's also a very
good situation to be in if you're
engaging in a good kind of psychotherapy
for example you won't immediately
dismiss some new idea because it's new
or different
the third thing so there's this intense
absorption there's this uh cognitive
flexibility and the third thing is
dissociation so you let go of what this
means for who you think you are and you
just kind of do it you can detach
yourself
now people spontaneously dissociate in
situations of stress or trauma for
example this can't be happening to me
and you know many uh rape victims uh
experience the rape as if they're
floating above their bodies feeling
sorry for what's happening to the person
below and that can be protective it can
keep you from having to engage in the
worst aspects of a traumatic situation
when it's happening but you can induce
that with hypnosis now we normally
dissociate to a certain extent right now
you're having Sensations in your bottom
touching the chair across from me but
hopefully you were not even aware of
that until I mentioned it to you if you
were we can stop the interview now and
you know yeah um so we do that as a way
of allocating our attention resources
where we want and not where we don't
want and in hypnosis you intensify those
three things and that allows you to
concentrate intently to have profound
effects on mind and body
um and and to alter your approach to
problems so that's what hypnosis is it's
a naturally occurring experience it
doesn't just happen when I dangle a
watch and find we don't you know digital
watches don't dangle very well anyway so
we don't do that but
um it's a it's a an unusual state that
many people can get into and people who
are hypnotizable get into naturally so
people who are more hypnotizable get
lost in sunsets you know they uh get
absorbed in movies they miss dinner
because they're so busy working on
something that capacity to deeply
allocate your attentional resources is
something that happens in hypnosis yeah
I definitely want to put a pen and drill
down on this notion of hypnotizability
but prior to that sure
um as we're kind of defining what we
what we mean when we talk about hypnosis
what you just described is clinical
hypnosis right we're mostly familiar
with this idea of of stage hypnosis The
Parlor trick version of it that you know
is the is the ire of your existence I'm
sure
um but how are these two things
different and you know sort of talk a
little bit about maybe that's a a larger
discussion about the history of this
modality sure well it might be that
might be a good way to frame it uh Rich
because hypnosis is the oldest western
conception of a Psychotherapy it's the
first time that a talking interaction uh
was thought to have therapeutic
potential
and it started 250 years ago with Franz
Anton Messmer in in Austria he thought
that he he would provoke what looked
like seizures he would take people next
to the what they called packets full of
metal filings with a slight magnetic
field and they would start to shake and
some would faint and he would use it to
treat a whole variety of well we would
then we would call psychiatric and
medical problems he became very popular
in Vienna so of course he left his wife
and family there and moved to Paris
where he started competing with these
French Physicians of the day and you
know uh Voltaire wrote to his brother
when his father was dying we did
everything we could to save father's
life we even sent the doctors away
and the main treatment in France at the
time was bloodletting so if you stayed
away from a French doctor by going to
Mesmer you would do better and he became
very popular in Paris but his theory
about why it happened was criticized
correctly that the the hypnotist doesn't
project a magnetic field on someone
wasn't it also about moving fluids into
balance yes that's right so rearranging
the the balance of magnetically charged
fluids in the body and it's the hypnosis
magnetism could he called it animal
magnetism at the time so the theory uh
the phenomenon was interesting the
theory was wrong he was have examined
that King Louie's behest by a French
panel of experts that included our own
Benjamin Franklin who was having a lot
of fun in Paris at the time right the
brilliant French chemist laboisier who
discovered you know this defined oxygen
chemistry and also invented the concept
of the gross national product shortly
before he was beheaded in the French
Revolution hence the term mesmerized
mesmerized that's it
and the other person on the panel was a
guy uh well known for his work on um on
separating the Mind from the body
Guillotine Dr guillotem Who invented the
guillotine was also on this panel wow he
created the mind-body problem in a sense
and and so that was a damaging blow to
hypnosis for for many many decades and
was that a scenario in which Mesmer
would go to kind of fancy dinner parties
and and and do it in you know kind of
highfalutin groups of high society
Mesmer was not a stage hypnotist he was
he was a dedicated healer and one of the
things that would notify that was was
noted about his offices where that they
were cheerful and bright and there would
be other patients teaching new patients
about what they learned uh unlike French
Physicians who had these dark Grim bare
offices that you kind of felt like you
were going to get sicker there and in
Mesmer he created this positive
expectation he was not a stage hypnotist
but it led his work led to stage
hypnosis and these guys one trick that
most people don't realize that they do
you know they make it seem that they
could do this to anybody and they can
get the football coach dancing like a
ballerina or somebody quacking like a
duck or lying between stiff between two
chairs they always screen a large number
of people and they bring them up they
try out a few things most of them go
back and sit down or they'll say to
somebody in the audience when they give
a suggestion to the audience if you
noticed your neighbor reacting a lot let
me know and so what they do is they go
through the large number of people to
get to the 10 or 15 percent who are very
hypnotizable and that's when the real
show begins so the first half of it is
just screening for hypnotizability and
getting those people up there and then
you can do the more extreme things
but as you mentioned I don't like it it
makes fools out of people
um it sometimes can be uh damaging or
upsetting
um my my late father who was a Pioneer
in hypnosis starting in the middle of
the last century
um I had a woman a neurologist called
him up and said Herbert you are going to
see this patient this morning because
she was found wandering in the streets
of Manhattan at 2 15 in the morning and
she's in some kind of weird mental state
and I don't know what it is but see her
and fix her you know and it turned out
that the trick in the stage hypnosis
show was that she was holding an
imaginary bird cage and it was a little
birdie in it and she was reacting just
that way and it always going great and
then he said now imagine that we're
opening the door and the bird will fly
away and she stood there and she started
to shake I mean it sounds pretty
innocent right
and she said the bird won't fly away the
bird won't fly away
and
um she got more and more anxious and
panicked and was clearly spoiling the
show so he just got her off the stage
and she's wandering around you know
Midtown Manhattan at two o'clock in the
morning
and it turned out that this apparently
innocent suggestion
um to her was a reminder of who she was
she was the trophy wife of a very
wealthy man and she felt like a bird in
a gilded cage and so when she decided
and people learn things about themselves
when they engage in hypnotic experiences
like this she sort of visualized that
and it was an important thing for her to
know but not under those circumstances
and and the practitioner didn't exit her
out of the hypnotic state so she was in
a persistent state of hypnosis wandering
around wow coupled with the upset it
sort of crystallizing what she kind of
knew about herself but hadn't really
faced so you know my father was able to
bring her out of the hypnotic State and
discuss whether what it meant and how to
get help for it now I don't I don't you
know I don't want to present that as
saying this is what happens every time
somebody else uses hypnosis it's not
dangerous it is hypnosis is just a state
of Highly focused attention so things
can go wrong in that state but then go
wrong in a lot of other states too but
it's one reason that I'm not wild about
stage hypnosis because these guys have
no clinical responsibility at all or
something happens so uh I just I think
it does give hypnosis in bed I mean
people are intrigued by it that's good
but it gives it a bad name as it should
it does have that veneer of of being
some kind of snake oil Carnival Barker
type of situation your work is really
about disabusing people of that notion
and you know not for nothing I mean your
dad really was
the pioneer of this field and I was
looking into him a little bit I know
that he treated Sipple and he was kind
of the toast of the town and would
dinette Elaine's like he seems like he
was quite the guy yeah
he was he said he didn't go to Broadway
Theater because what happens in his
office is more interesting you know
but most of the theater people came to a
Lanes afterwards anyways so he saw him
there yeah but interestingly it seems
like uh it's not a case in which you
grew up
uh you know thinking you were gonna
pursue this craft as well this science
as well especially at least it was
interesting I'll tell you a story when I
I published a book some years ago living
beyond limits that had talked about
treating cancer patients and some about
hypnosis Terry Gross was interviewing me
on fresh air and she said you know I
happen to know that your father is a
well-known hypnotist um did he ever try
to hypnotize you when you were a child
you know suddenly she got journalistic
on me and I said to her Terry I don't
think so
she said okay okay we're done with it
but well you kind of dodged the question
though of
um whether or not your dad was
hypnotizing you oh no he wasn't he was
and you know there are a couple of
things at least not that I remember
right uh but no but I was very
interested in the dinner table
conversations I mean it was kind of fun
to listen to this and every once in a
while when he'd be film making a movie
of a patient he had a patient who had
what we now called
um non-epileptic of epilepsy where you
don't actually have a seizure focus in
the brain but you act like you're having
a seizure and
um she was just having these events at
any time anywhere her husband's desk at
the factory near their home was moved to
be near the door so he could run home
and help her so they filmed my father
hypnotizing her and inducing one of
these teachers and you know the the the
story is maybe you can't stop it but you
can start it and that's the way of
teaching you control over this mind-body
relationship so he had her do that and
I'm watching her you know like a fish
flopping um on the on the sofa there I'm
thinking this is this is pretty
interesting so I was I was attracted to
it although of course I tried everything
else first but my parents my mother is
also a psychiatrist and psychoanalyst
um and uh my parents told me that I was
free to be any kind of psychiatrist I
wanted to be
so I took him up on it right here I am
right and yeah here you are I mean you
you sort of ventured West you started
with a focus on philosophy that's right
going to medical school you venture to
San Francisco thinking it'll be a
short-term thing and you've been at
Stanford for quite some time that's
right yeah I just I couldn't couldn't go
back I loved it I loved it out here
right so so talk a little bit about
um the you mentioned the my mind-body
connection and I think that's a really
important point in broadening our
understanding of this world of hypnosis
well you know uh you know you mentioned
snakehold earlier and one of the things
that really troubles me saddens me about
the way hypnosis has been understood and
treated is you know there have been a
lot of problems with medications too you
know we have 60 000 opioid overdose
deaths in the United States last year
medications have their problems too and
I'm a physician I use medications I'm
not against that but you know we the
major evolutionary Advantage we have as
humans is this big brain on the top of
our bodies it's connected to every organ
in the body and but we it doesn't come
with a user's manual and so we don't
take full advantage of what it can do
and we underestimate we tend to think
that the real treatments in medicine are
ingestion injection or incision you know
that the body is like a broken car you
just replace the part and everything
will be fine and otherwise you're not
really doing anything you're just
talking to the person
and I'll tell you rich the day that I
really that turned me around about this
I was a um a third year medical student
um at Harvard I was in pediatric
rotation the nurse says to me Spiegel
your next patient is in room 342 and I'm
following the sound of the wheezing down
the hall
and there's this 15 year old girl
redhead bolt upright Knuckles white
struggling for breath you could hear the
wheezing her mother standing there
crying they had tried to use
subcutaneous epinephrine twice it didn't
work they were thinking about general
anesthesia and starting her on steroids
and I didn't know what else to do so I
said you want to learn a breathing
exercise and she nods and I had take
started a hypnosis course and so I got
her hypnotized and then I realized we
hadn't gone to asthma in the course yet
so I came up with a very clever idea I
said each Breath You Take will be a
little deeper and a little easier and
within five minutes she's lying back in
bed her Knuckles aren't white her
mother's not crying
she's breathing almost normally
and the nurse ran out of the room my
intern comes to find me and I figure
he's going to Pat me on the back and say
good job speaker how would you do you
know he said the nurse filed a complaint
with the nursing supervisor that you
violated Massachusetts law by
hypnotizing a minor without parental
consent
and you know Massachusetts has a lot of
weird laws but that's not on the list
and her mother was standing next to me
when I did it so he says to me you're
going to have to stop doing it and so I
mean this just observing that I think
you know there is something here there's
something to this the brain can really
control what's going on in the body even
in rather extreme circumstances so they
told me that it was dangerous and I said
you're going to put her on steroids and
put her under general anesthesia and am
I talking to her is dangerous you know
and he said well you may not be able to
follow her and I said well I'll you know
I'm in Boston I'll follow her as long as
it's not necessary and he said you got
to stop doing it I said I'll tell you
what
as long as she's my patient I'm not
going to tell her anything I know is not
true so if you want to take me off the
case go ahead but otherwise I'm not so
there was a council of War among the my
intern the resident the chief resident
and the attending that weekend and they
came back on Monday with a radical idea
never been tried before they said let's
ask the patients
she said I like this you know and and
that just that observation that just
something I said to her that using this
simple straightforward undangerous
technique could produce such a radical
change in such a short time really
hooked me I mean I you know I'd learned
a lot a fair amount about hypnosis
growing up but nothing like this where
you see it happen
and and that I think is one of the
tremendous advantages right now
um is that you will know very quickly
whether it's going to help you or not
doesn't help everybody but it helps a
lot of people and you can feel it right
away which is unusual among
psychotherapies even among medications
often takes a while to to feel the
effect it's interesting that that breath
is such a core critical kind of conduit
to achieving these states
so talk a little bit about the impact of
breath I mean breath is interesting
you're talking about voluntary and
involuntary actions you know the
distinction between the conscious mind
and the unconscious mind breath is sort
of unique in that we we you know it we
breathe no matter what we what you know
what we do our body will take care of
that but we can kind of override that
and control that as well it's one of I
don't know how many other kind of
physiological you know biomechanical you
know things that fall into that category
that's exactly right it's a very astute
observation and I'm researching that now
with my colleague and friend Andrew
huberman we've we've got some funding to
study breath work and compare it to
other forms of uh Mind Body Control and
you're exactly right that the
interesting thing I mean the centers for
breath control are right at the at the
tip of the spinal cord so between the
brain and the spinal cord so they're
also right at the edge of conscious
versus unconscious control so as you
said we can consciously control our
breathing but we usually don't and
um it seems to me to be a pathway into
this mind-body connection just because
it's at that Tipping Point between
conscious and unconscious and because
also the way we breathe affects our
autonomic nervous system so if if you
think like your heart for a minute when
you inhale
you inhale by reducing pressure
expanding the diaphragm down expanding
the rib cage and so you pull in because
you create a bit of a vacuum hair into
your lungs that also reduces blood flow
um to the heart
because it's coming up through the vena
cava into the heart and it slows it down
a bit so the the sonoatrial node says
wait a minute there's less blood coming
we better speed up heart rate and blood
pressure so you get a bit of a pump of
your sympathetic nervous system
and then when you exhale you increase
pressure you increase return to the
heart and so the parasympathetic the
self-soothing system that opposes the
sympathetic nervous system kicks in and
and slows down your heart rate and your
blood pressure we do this all the time
the it's called respiratory sinus
arrhythmia and it is a actually a very
good measure of Health the capacity to
self-soothe can you turn on that
parasympathetic system when you need it
and if you breathe in certain ways one
is called cyclic sign where if you do
this you inhale part way
hold it
fill your lungs and then slowly exhale
what you're doing is privileging your
parasympathetic over your sympathetic
nervous system and it's a nice natural
relaxation experience and Andrew and I
have found that it actually improves
mood and makes people feel more rested
when when they do it so we think there
are ways of controlling your breathing
that can enhance your capacity to
self-soothe and what is it about breath
that helps induce this hypnotic State
well it's not necessary but typically
um when I do a hypnotic induction I
combine looking up and closing your eyes
with taking a deep breath and slowly
exhaling and I think in part it's
triggering this self-soothing
parasympathetic response because one of
the things you can get all aroused in
hypnosis but typically the arousal even
if it's mental arousal doesn't
necessarily bring with it physical
arousal and that's how hypnosis is a
very good stress reduction technique
because you can be facing something that
makes you anxious but you can still be
having a physical experience of being
comfortable you can dissociate your
mental from your physiological arousal
and so the breath is a way of helping to
speed the transition into a state where
whatever it is you're focusing on or
concentrating on your body can feel
relaxed and comfortable and that begins
to teach you how to control stress and
what do we know and and perhaps uh have
yet to learn about what's going on
uh
neurochemically in the brain when you
induce a hypnotic State like what are
the brain what aspects of the brain are
being turned on turned off Etc we've
been studying that for the past decade
and um we've discovered some things that
that really begin to make a lot of sense
uh and one of them I'll talk first about
neural function in the brain and then
neurochemistry
one of the things that happens when
somebody goes into a hypnotic state is
that they turn down activity in the
dorsal anterior cingulate the salience
network the way to think about the
Cingular gyrus is it's a bundle of
nerves that looks like a c on its end
here and it it goes under this arable
cortex and over the limbic system and
this part here in the front the dorsal
anterior cingulate cortex is part of the
salience network it's part of the brain
that is a context detector and it tells
you should I pay attention or not
and so if a loud noise suddenly happens
you startle and you go turn your
attention to where it is social media is
very good at using this you know they
they'll float something by you that
sounds a little scary or threatening and
you suddenly you know detach from what
you were paying attention to and do
that's the salience network in hypnosis
you turn down activity in that brain
region
and in fact in another study we looked
at the prevalence of neurotransmitter
activity in those regions and you see
more Gaba activity in the anterior
cingulate of people who were very
hypnotizable so they they have more
ability to inhibit it's an inhibitory
neurotransmitter it's one that is
activated by anti-anxiety drugs
um and there's greater ability there
because of the higher prevalence of this
inhibitory neurotransmitter to inhibit
the salience activity so it's one thing
that helps you concentrate intently
you're less likely to worry about what
else you might be thinking of or are
thinking about
the second thing that happens is hire
what we call functional connectivity
that's if one region is active the other
region is active that region is inactive
the other region tends to be inactive
between the dorsal lateral prefrontal
cortex on the left which is part of the
executive control Network it's the part
of my brain I'm hopefully using now as
I'm describing this to you and the
insula that's another part of the
salience network that's a major
mind-body pathway so it helps your brain
control what's happening in your body
control gastrointestinal function
control autonomic activity and so you
have a greater ability in hypnosis to
control what's happening in your body
like that 15 year old girl with her
asthma attack
the third thing that happens is you have
inverse functional connectivity so when
one region is active the other is
inactive between the executive control
Network and the posterior part of the
cingulate cortex that's what we have
called the default mode Network and it's
a part of the brain that's active when
you're thinking about yourself when
you're reflecting on who you are and
what it means it's a part of the brains
that where activity goes down in
experienced meditators
and of course part of meditation is to
sort of detach from your selfness you
know to just experience things and not
judge them or see what they mean for you
and that's a mechanism of dissociation
in hypnosis so we found that a lot of
things that we know from the
phenomenology of hypnosis are actually
happening in specific regions of the
brain that should control that kind of
activity and is this the result of fmri
testing that you've been able to discern
all of this yeah we've screened hundreds
and hundreds of uh
thank the fully Cooperative Stanford
students and picked out the ones who on
formal testing are very high and very
low in hepatizability
we get put them in the scanner the highs
and the lows we give them hypnotic
instructions and we see what happens in
the brains only of the high
hypnotizables and only when they're in
the hypnotic conditions and that's what
enabled us to observe what's going on in
the brain and on that subject of
hypnotizability uh let's talk a little
bit more about that I mean first how do
you determine whether somebody has a
high receptivity to it and secondarily
to that like is that sort of a pre a
preset that people come into the world
with is it malleable is it something
that can be shifted with technique
um we're doing some research now that
that adds to another body of research
over the last decade or so showing that
there does seem to be a genetic
component to hypnotizability
um that particularly people with a
certain
um uh polymorphism
um of uh the the production of dopamine
a neurotransmitter that's prominent in
the prefrontal cortex and throughout the
brain
um uh if they produce just enough so
this is an enzyme catecholomethyl
transferase it's an enzyme that
metabolizes dopamine and if you if
you're at a point where you don't
metabolize it too quickly or too slowly
those people seem to be more highly
hypnotizable and related people people
with in general genetic commonalities
tend to be more similarly hypnotizable
than people who are unrelated and so
there is some evidence that
it may have to do with this genetic
variation in neurotransmitter metabolism
but
um there's also evidence
um Josephine Hilgard published a book
called personality hypnosis where she
looked at the early life histories of
former Stanford students of Stanford
students and found that higher
hypnotizability was associated with one
positive and one negative thing
imaginative involvements children who
had been raised to have imaginative
involvements their parents read stories
to them every night they played games in
their imagination turn out to be more
highly advertisable but sadly also
children who have been physically and
sexually abused are more highly
hypnotizable and it may be that it's a
kind of protective defense mechanism if
you're going through terrible
experiences right because they developed
the ability to disassociate when their
brain was still malleable that's exactly
right I had one patient who said I just
go to a mountain Meadow full of
wildflowers when my father and his
friends were abusing me you know that's
the way she did with it and so uh
there's a developmental part of it but
the other part of the story
is that most children are highly
hypnotizable right that's what I was
thinking because they're less calcified
in their neural Pathways that's that's
part of it and because they're for
children you know knowledge and emotion
and experience are all kind of one thing
you know it's why work is play for kids
you know it's a shame that we make them
into little adults because they love
doing whatever it is they're doing they
just get fully engaged hypnotically in a
way and whatever they're doing and you
call your eight-year-old in for dinner
and she doesn't hear you she's out doing
whatever she does in adolescence when we
develop what the psychologist Piaget
used to call formal operations where you
kind of privilege logic over experience
many people lose to some degree that
hypnotizability and by the time you're
20 21 the level you have is what you're
going to have 25 years later and
um they did a study at Stanford in which
they blindly retested students
um and at 25 years after they've taken
their psych one class and found that
there was a 0.7 correlation between
their original hypnotizability and the
one they had at age 45 or 46. is that
zimbardo yeah
did you really I was not part of that
code you weren't part of that cohort did
he did he read the his I mean
remember yes that's right you were there
in the 80s you were uh at Stanford well
you know so what it suggests is that
once you get into early adulthood it's a
very stable trait it just doesn't change
very much and and so some people who
retain it I think have brains that have
been
um uh have grown into a a relationship
particularly between and we've done some
neuroimaging on this too the
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex and the
anterior cingulate and people the
students we studied who were more highly
hypnotizable had more functional
connective activity between the
executive control and the salience
networks than the low hypnotizables so
when they thought about something they
tended to coordinate that with the part
of the brain that says is this worth
thinking about or not whereas and it's
interesting if you see really low
hypnotizable people as adults and I see
a lot of them they come to me they want
to be hypnotized and they're not
hypnotizable they're very critical and
and they evaluate things carefully and
they argue and they raise questions
which is all good but it's a kind of
non-hypnotic way of responding right
it's it's sort of an external external
evidence of uh non-hypnotizability
through character traits right just
being kind of skeptical and defensive
perhaps a little bit that's yeah that's
exactly right but you've developed this
test the Spiegel test right to kind of
easily in a facile way determine uh
hypnotizability will you indulge me in
taking me through this sure I'd be glad
to well the first part
um my father observed he used to have
people
um you know look up at the ceiling get a
light on the ceiling and close their
eyes and actually he noticed that the
woman I mentioned earlier who was
extremely hypnotizable and having these
seizures these pseudoseizures that when
she looked up he noticed that all he
could see was the sclera the whites of
her eyes he couldn't see her Iris or her
pupil at all and his next patient the
following Monday was a very rigid
obsessional lawyer who just you know
fought him every bit of the way he had
him look up and the guy had to bring his
eyes back down
and he was not at all hypnotizable so my
father started measuring and and there
seemed to be a a modest but real
correlation between this measurement
that he called the eye roll and and the
rest of the test which only takes about
five minutes but measures hypnotic
experience and behavior so I do the
whole test with every patient that I see
um to determine how hypnotizable they
are so I can I can see for a start if
you want to see what you're gonna take
my glasses off or I can leave it on oh
you can leave them on it all right so
look up all the way up past your
eyebrows keep looking up and slowly
close your eyes close so you would be
open you would be about a two out of
four I can see about half Iris and he
has Clara and but there's a bit of a
convergence that usually adds a point
your your left eye tends to to converge
to the middle when you yeah I have a
weak left eye yeah I could see that but
um so you're you'd be a two or three so
you'd be in a sort of mineral to high
but not extremely high range would be my
guess just from that now there's the
rest of the test I can do it if you want
to see formally how hypnotizable you are
right interesting what is it about the
the optic nerve I mean obviously the
optic nerve is part of the brain but you
know that test on a surface level feels
very you know kind of correlative but
not necessarily you know causative right
right so how you know what what is that
relationship between site seems to be
very important Well site is important
and I think you know part of why I ask
people to look up and close their eyes
is I want them to be alert and awake but
turning inward we're used to going to
sleep when we close our eyes so the idea
that you can be reflective and intensely
concentrating but your eyes are closed
means that you're cutting off your
scanning awareness you know as we're
pretty pathetic creatures in in the in
the animal world and one way that we
keep our ourselves alive is by scanning
the visual environment to see if there
are any threats and with hypnosis you're
kind of trusting the outside world to
leave you alone and turning inwards so
part of it is that just closing your eye
looking up closing your eyes and there's
an old zen practice called looking at
the third eye where it's part of
meditation and you look up and close
your eyes but there are other things
about the neurophysiology of eye
movement
the third fourth and sixth cranial nerve
nuclei the control eye movement and
control the lowering of the eyelid and
that are involved in the the exercise
that I did with you just now are also
surrounded by the reticular activating
system which is a part of the brain stem
and the lower part of the brain that it
modulates arousal
and drugs that affect
um level of arousal also affect eye
movement so if you take barbiturates you
get nystagmus your eyes move back and
forth like this they control the size of
the pupils so stimulates enhance the
size of the pupil opioids constrict the
pupil and so there's a lot about arousal
that is very closely linked to eye
movement and that I think is one reason
that these two may be connected with
respect to the other senses though and
and thinking about hypnosis in terms of
absorption and suggestibility uh I can't
help but think about sense memory and
how powerful things like smell or
hearing a song that you haven't heard
for a very long time that can evoke a
very specific vivid memory like how do
those other senses play into this kind
of
personality well
what they show is that they can't you
know what we're doing with this eye
movement test is just seeing what it
tells us about your ability to
manipulate these other things but we
have plenty of evidence that hypnosis
can be used to alter perception
somatosensory perception visual
perception auditory perception and we
did one study where we um
showed a group of Highly hypnotizable
people a color grid like a Mondrian
painting and had them in hypnosis drain
the color out of the color grid and
after a while they said yeah it looks
black white and gray to me and then we
showed them some black white and gray
grids and said make them colorful and
they did that and they could
convincingly to themselves see it
differently and what we found using pet
was that there was when they were
draining the color they turned down
activity in the lingual infusiform
gyride in the occipital cortex that
process color vision and when they were
adding color to the black and white grid
they increased activity in those same
regions so they could change it in both
directions and I call that my believing
a seeing experiment you know that with
hypnosis you can get highly hypnotizable
people to literally change their
perception of color right and it's not
just the reporting it looks different
they see it differently yeah and we've
seen the same thing using EEG on on pain
perception and others uh at the
University of Montreal there's a very
good research group here rainville that
has
taught people to use hypnosis to reduce
pain so you administer some shocks and
you say your hand is an ice water in
hypnosis and they turn down activity in
the somatosensory cortex where you
process ultimately sensation
and if you use different words in
hypnosis you say well the Pain's here
but it won't bother you which is sort of
what people on opioids feel you turn
down activity in the anterior cingulate
cortex and you still get analgesia so
you can use hypnosis to change not just
how the brain reacts to things but how
the brain processes things you
experience them differently
prophets Walk Among Us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years I've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share those
that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing and so I've dedicated my career
to tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why I'm proud to announce the release of
my new book voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration and Timeless wisdom that
transpires each week on the ritual
podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
Exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying Standalone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday Prophets
physically interact with the
life-changing ideas contained with that
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
it's utterly fascinating and of course
the the dark side of my personality
can't help but think about The
Manchurian Candidate you know example of
how this could be you know weaponized
for nefarious means
um you know I I you know the the sort of
what you're what you're taught in you
know grade one hypnosis training is oh
no people would never do anything that
they otherwise wouldn't do I would like
to think that but look
you know we live in a country where you
know a substantial minority of the
population actually thinks that Trump
won the presidential election you know
um so
it is entirely possible for us human
beings to succumb to social influence
and believe things that are just flat
out not true
um that's a little scary it goes beyond
hypnosis but if you know it does suggest
that it's a mass hypnosis of sorts I
think I think so I think it was I pay
attention to something else it's like a
giant you know big stage stage hypnosis
you know and you look at what happens in
those rallies and what people will go
for you know when somebody tells them
this is the right thing to do and this
is what must happen and all this it's a
little scary but it's not hypnosis fault
you know leave my specialty out of this
but I I do think
um so is there a Manchurian Candidate
thing possible sure do
um I don't think it happens very often
and I do think people are capable of
resisting
um even in a hypnotic circumstance
um doing something that they feel deeply
is wrong but on the other hand we all
get you know we've all had that it
seemed like a good idea at the time
experience you know and you wonder what
the hell was I thinking when I did that
and so I I think anything that has the
power to help has the power to hurt in a
clinical hypnosis setting is there a
sense of how long you can create a
persistent hypnotic state does it wear
off with time or can somebody kind of
remain in that state indefinitely well
I know a few people may have but I
um let me put it this way
um
I I have to I can answer that question
in two ways typically in in the sort of
formal sense if I hypnotize somebody in
my office they were very hypnotizable
they're in a trance and I get called
away and forget to come back or
something usually the worst thing will
happen is they'll eventually fall asleep
and when they wake up
they'll be out of the state some people
can begin to wonder what's going on and
bring themselves out
but the other side of that coin is look
what I do to put someone into a hypnotic
state if they're hypnotizable is pretty
straightforward very fast easy to do and
so that means that people who have that
ability go into those States like that
all the time anyway and they come out of
them so uh there's a great psychologist
at University of Minnesota called Rocky
telegan who developed an absorption
scale
it's a measure of how often you get
caught up in sunsets or movies you
forget to come home for dinner you just
get totally engaged and absorbed and
those people when they're tested
formally are more hypnotizable than
those who don't have these high
absorption scores so what it suggest is
you know what it's happening all the
time anyway people who are hypnotizable
are going into hypnotic-like States
getting absorbed and engaged and then
coming out of them again
we we associate hypnosis with pinwheels
and you know watches swaying back and
forth and all the like I feel like
hypnosis needs clinical hypnosis needs a
bit of a rebranding to bring it into the
21st century like if you called it
something else like the neuro-absorption
protocol or something like that I feel
like it would it would it would have
attraction that uh it it kind of is in
need of you know you're really good at
this rich and if you have some good
advice
um
like beating the dead horse of this term
hypnosis well here's the thing though I
I mean I'm the term I'm playing around
with in my head is transformation but
with a c not with an S I like that that
it's a it's a way of of making
transforming yourself making changes in
a hurry and using the state
um and I on the other hand there's a
sort of a impish part of me that is
saying you know maybe we ought to just
say folks hypnosis dangerously effective
you know that uh if people are a little
you know a little bit scared of it they
might actually pay more attention to it
so and I've tried using other terms but
you know when I do it everybody says
come on you're talking about hypnosis
give me a break you know so I I hear
what you're saying and I I think we have
a problem but I don't know whether we
make the problem better by trying to
call it something else or by
acknowledging what it is but expanding
upon what it is yeah interesting
transformation I like that you like it
well let's talk about use cases uh you
mentioned pain management
opioid addiction there are you know I
think most people associate hypnosis or
at least the efficacy of it with smoking
cessation you know we're in Los Angeles
there's lots of kind of quote unquote
like celebrity hypnotists people pay in
unbelievable amount of money to go see
these people to quit smoking I don't
know whether those people fall into the
category of of being legitimate clinical
hypnotists but there are you know
there's a wide spectrum of use cases
here so let's talk about that for a few
sure I'd be glad to well certainly uh I
I can save some of these wealthy people
in La a lot of money by saying you know
we we do this on reverie our hypnosis
happened there we did choose a different
name by the way we didn't call it a
hypnosis app but it's you know
r-e-v-e-r-i and we have interactive
digital hypnosis there where we treat
pain we treat stress we help people
focus their attention more we help them
control
um uh trouble sleeping insomnia trouble
eating
um and smoking control we help people
stop smoking we get one out of five
people just using the app stop smoking
now it's not everybody but that's
definitive sounds pretty good it
compares favorably with a lot of other
things I I had one we're doing a number
of studies on this now and I had one uh
woman came in we do a careful evaluation
in the study and she sort of at first
didn't like it when we taught it to her
but she went home
and she did the exercise and she said
cigarette who wants that and she said I
haven't smoked a cigarette since and she
said this is some crazy ass Voodoo [ __ ]
and I mean that in a good way she said
you know that's amazing and she she said
her friends are amazed that she stopped
and she's helping her friend stop so it
can be a place where you turn a corner
where you can just because you
concentrate intently you're cognitively
flexible you're dissociating from your
usual pattern of associations that lead
you to have another cigarette that you
can focus on respecting and protecting
your body rather than fighting smoking
um one of one of the strategies that
hypnotists are pretty good at is saying
to patients the worst thing I could do
is tell you don't think about purple
elephants right what are you thinking
about so if you tell yourself don't
smoke what do you want to do you want to
smoke but if I tell you to think about
your body as if it were a trusting
innocent child that had to take into it
anything you put into it even if it were
damaged by it
um that's a whole different way of
thinking about it and you can feel good
about yourself right away you're not
depriving yourself
you're protecting and respecting your
body and that's something you can be for
and that's something you've written
about and talked about a lot that you
you know came to a turning point about
how you were treating your body and how
your body was treating you and
everything changed when you did that
yeah the the solution's a little bit
different though but I think what's
interesting about addiction
and perhaps this is related to pain
management is there is a physiological
thing occurring in your body that's
creating discomfort right whether it's
the the chemical craving for the
substance or the the you know neural
impulse that's creating the pain
um that somehow is being overridden by
this hypnotic practice well you know
part of it is that for pain for example
our brains are used to treating all pain
as if it were acute pain you know if
you've just broken your ankle you better
know about it and do something about it
but after a while you know even as it's
healed and moving it doesn't necessarily
do any damage your brain tends to react
in the same way it learns that something
really bad happened to your ankle and
you better do something about it
um and so it's partly learning teaching
your brain how to reinterpret the
peripheral input so that you're it's not
you know it becomes like the you know
the the loudest kid in the classroom you
know you just pay more attention to them
even though you don't want to I saw a
lovely woman yesterday I hadn't met
before who had a terrible car accident
like 30 years ago
has had 10 surgeries on her legs as a
result has back pain
and it's just frustrated beyond words
and his is on a bunch of
um uh you know oxycodone and other
opioid treatments why they're telling or
get off them because you're going to get
addicted which happens and she herself
was a clinical hypnotist and she said I
help a lot of other people but I can't
seem to help myself and I she was
moderately hypnotizable when we started
her pain was six out of ten which she
said I can sort of tolerate but if it
gets to seven or eight I can't
and she has a bath her insurance company
gave her a walk-in bath because she has
to get around with a walker now I said
you're in your bath you're warm tingling
numb feel your body floating and um and
I said there's one other thing I want
you to think about I'm suspecting that
you're pretty angry at your body
and she said you bet I am and I said
well you know she had actually two new
grandchildren and I said if your little
granddaughter were in pain and we're
crying what would you do would you get
angry at her she said hell no I'd you
know hug her and comfort her and soothe
her until she felt better and I said
good that's what you're going to do for
your body
and so I want you to imagine comforting
your body the way you comfort your great
granddaughter and within a few minutes
like 10 minutes the pain was down to two
and she said I can live with that wow
and and she you know she was sort of
surprised but she wasn't I mean she does
hypnosis for a living but she couldn't
do it for herself right right right and
but part of it is also the strategy it's
not just you know can you change it but
how do you approach the problem and
again I want it to be what you're for
not what you're against
so she was she was able to do it and and
felt you know much better than she had a
few minutes earlier and it seems like a
big piece in that strategy is this idea
of self-love and self-respect that's
right yeah that's right you know you
know I I had a cancer patient who said
you know I used to treat my body like it
was my dog you know sit here go over
there do this do that you know and when
I got cancer I realized it wasn't
listening to me anymore and one you know
you you feel frustrated anxious but you
know we'd rather mostly be mad than said
we'd rather you know be angry at
something that should be better or
different than than realistically assess
what's going on and part of what we
don't fully live as if we understood is
that we are in full charge of our bodies
and they'll do things they'll the body
can make you feel bad but you can make
the body feel bad and if you can learn
to treat it with respect the way you
would any other creature that depended
upon you you'll live better within your
body and your body will help you live
better too and does that strategy hold
true for other use cases like you
mentioned the asthma story or uh you
know Sleep Disorders what about you know
obsessive thoughts OCD trauma
um
with trauma for sure that's
um uh in part because people are in
dissociative States when they're
traumatized and
when you get things like post-traumatic
stress disorder and this is not a sort
of One-Shot pure situation but one that
I use in in treatment
um is you get people to think about
their traumatic experience from a
different point of view we know that
most of the treatments
for PTSD involve what's called
exposure-based therapy or cognitive
restructuring about the trauma or some
combination of the two but you have to
reapproach the trauma and given that
flashbacks are a symptom of PTSD I've
often wondered why not why doesn't the
cure itself you know okay you're getting
the exposure why aren't you feeling
better because you're not in control
you're feeling re-attacked by the memory
or the flashback the way you were when
the trauma happened and so what you need
to do is approach it in a way that helps
you
take control of what you can control and
give up the fantasy of control where you
can't most people would rather feel
guilty than helpless they'd rather blame
themselves with the fantasy that somehow
I could have prevented it from happening
it might not have happened again and and
if you can get them to face it but see
it from a different point of view while
they control their physical reaction
they don't feel reassaulted by the
memory because they're bringing it on
so I had a woman come to see me to use
hypnosis because she it was an attempted
rape if she was getting dark she was
coming home from the store this guy
jumped her and wanted to drag her up
into her apartment and she couldn't
really see his face and she was hoping
the hypnosis would help revivify her
image of the face and occasionally that
can happen but she said I still can't
see much but she said you know what I do
see and I said your body is safe and
comfortable you know you may be
remembering this but your body is
protected you're not going to be harmed
now and she said you know what
he didn't just want to rape me he wanted
to kill me if he got me up to my
apartment and he she followed him so
hard he gave her a basil or skull
fracture she actually had a seizure and
was taken to the hospital afterwards
and I said all right now your body is
safe I want you to picture on the other
side of the screen uh what you did to
protect yourself
everybody who's in a situation like that
comes up with some strategy maybe freeze
don't say anything don't antagonize him
it may be fighting but they do something
but they often don't appreciate what
they did and she said you know what he's
surprised that I'm fighting so hard he
didn't think I would so she came away
from that experience with a completely
different view of what had happened that
not that she got herself hurt and
shouldn't have but that she probably
saved her own life right
and that's the kind of thing you can do
with hypnosis you can hold those two
thoughts in your mind look at what
happened and see it from a new point of
view but the key piece being here is is
volition right if you're going to
revisit trauma PTSD you know without
your volition you're being visited by
these traumatic events that are kind of
enhancing the traumatic experience
versus uh you know getting into a state
where you can welcome some aspect of
that experience in a in a safe
environment so that you can work through
it yes
that's well put and that's uh but you
know people worry hypnosis means losing
control it doesn't it means enhancing
control of your brain end up your
experience so part of what gives truth
to what they're experiencing is they're
feeling in control when they're doing it
and they're saying you know I know what
I could control I can I have to face
what I couldn't control and part of what
is so damaging about trauma why people
have post-traumatic stress disorder why
one out of four combat veterans comes
back with PTSD is that you feel trauma
is the experience of being made into an
object a thing the victim of Nature's
indifference somebody else's rage
um and so that means you're stuck in one
view of who you are and the minute you
think about it you feel like you are
once again an object with no control and
with hypnosis and in Psychotherapy
you're parsing that experience to say
yes there were aspects you did not
control but there were aspects you did
and here's what you did
I know you talked about this with Andrew
but I think it brings up an interesting
discussion in a broader context around
how we think about our own exposure to
things that perhaps could traumatize us
you know we're in a culture of trigger
warnings and safe spaces and things like
that I just saw it wasn't a Spiegel eye
roll but it was a bit of an eye roll
um you know and and as a psychiatrist
understanding that
we have to kind of annure ourselves to
exposure on some level as a means of
strengthening our resilience our
emotional resilience to things that
might disturb us I I completely agree
with you and I I just think this whole
trigger warning thing
his his misguided
um that is you have to you know life is
full of tragedy and misery you know as
we know all too well if you just you
know
gaze at a newspaper listen to the news
every once in a while people are
suffering you know lethal assaults on
their countries all kinds of horrible
things are happening a million Americans
died of covid in the last couple of
years I mean there were terrible things
happening
and you can't just have live in this
happy fantasy that things aren't
happening it's a matter of how you face
it and if you think about the fact that
what we've just discussed that the main
treatment for PTSD so these are people
who have been traumatized who are very
symptomatic is not to have them avoid
and run away from it get a trigger
warning don't think about this it's to
have them face it in a controlled
supportive thoughtful way
and frankly that's the only way we
humans are going to survive we have to
face our own vulnerabilities and you
know the term trigger warning is an
unfortunate one because you know
triggers are causing a lot of the trauma
uh that we're facing now by the time an
American child has grown up they've seen
20 000 people killed mostly with guns on
television
um and uh yet they're desensitized to it
because almost all of those situations
are ones in which you don't care about
the person who's killed you know the
cops got the bad guy kind of thing so we
desensitize people to real tragic
horrifying trauma uh and you know
there's a big debate now about should we
show these poor children who have been
killed show what's left of their bodies
after one of these exploding bullets
hits them and I think we're sanitizing
it too much you know it's painful to see
it but we damn well ought to know what's
happening to people and the fact that
there are 400 million firearms in this
country and 330 million people
um and that it's a leading cause of
death among young people now is gun
deaths we've got to face that we've got
to do something about it yeah perhaps
it's a different form of of psyop or
mass hypnosis the extent to which we
we've been you know kind of inoculated
against the horrors of of that type of
activity you're exactly right we're
sanitizing it and we shouldn't you know
at least face it see what you're doing
let's talk about Amnesia I think there's
an interesting discussion to be had
around memory and and hypnosis people
that you know perhaps they've they've
gone through some sort of traumatic
experience they can't remember it and
hypnosis being a vehicle for recapturing
lost memory yes
it's um that's the dissociative part of
hypnosis where you can sort of
disconnect your memory of a certain
experience particularly and often
because it arouses very strong emotion
that you have trouble understandably
dealing with and so one form of emotion
regulation is to just keep the content
out of Consciousness so that you don't
get so upset when you when you remember
it and you know to some extent we all
have you know
um uh dissociation or loss of memory of
things you know you you may have had the
experience of going back you go back to
Stanford and you look around the
buildings you were in and you may start
remembering things that you hadn't
thought of sure you know why do we do
that why do we go back for reunions you
know to to see people but also to stir
up memories again so that isn't formal
dissociative Amnesia but it is the case
that the sort of lack of cues that would
link you to a given memory may make the
memory harder to recover on the other
hand there are situations where people
literally lose recollection for hours or
days people who are in the World Trade
Center attack many of them couldn't
recall
events that happened and it was probably
a good thing because at the time they
also narrowed the focus of attention I
treated one woman who was getting out of
the the second tower that fell and she's
telling herself I just want to put one
foot in front of the other and if I get
to the ground floor I'll be okay and
when she did the other building
collapsed and she was blown through a
window but managed to survive wow and
she was angry at herself she said I lied
to myself I wasn't really safe well of
course she wasn't really safe but the
best thing she could do her survival
technique was to just focus on what she
could do and that's one step in front of
the other going down the stairs and so
we do that so the experience was encoded
in this in this way there's been
research for example about people who
are the victims of shootings or armed
robberies and the cops asked them
um what did the guy they give a
brilliant description of the gun you
know it was a black revolver and it was
you know eight inches long whatever it
was and they said what'd the guy look
like they said I don't know because
they're in a hypnotic-like state they're
so focused on what's likely to kill them
that's all they're paying attention to
so some of the Amnesia is you really
didn't acquire much information at that
right it just didn't imprint right the
get-go but in other cases There Was You
may remember down not far from here
Chowchilla California there was a school
bus
um uh kidnapping these guys overtook a
school bus buried the whole bus with the
kids in it in some trench somewhere I
don't remember that two days and they
fight so they found they they managed to
dig their way out and fortunately the
kids were okay physically
um the bus driver couldn't remember much
about the guys the car that overtook the
bus he was hypnotized and they asked him
to look at the front of the car that was
overtaking the bus and say what he could
remember about the license plate and
only under hypnosis he recalled all of
the correct numbers and letters of the
license plate in the wrong order wow but
that was enough and that led the police
to find and arrest the guys and they're
running in jail somewhere for having
done it so there are times when you know
the intensity of the experience will
tend to compartmentalize your memories
make it harder to access them but not
impossible and hypnosis particularly
done in a way that reassures people
about their current comfort and safety
can sometimes help with that yeah
there's some debate it seems uh as to
the efficacy of of using hypnosis in a
court context right you can see you can
foresee many situations in which this
would be powerful for either the
prosecution or the the defense to you
know have a hypnotic uh you know induce
a witness into a hypnotic state to
remember these things or to have them
testify as to what occurred during a
hypnotic date and introduce that in
court is that a state by state thing or
what is the court system yeah in most
States now California has a decision
called people versus Shirley where it
was a situation
that was the worst possible use of
hypnosis this was some guy brought a
woman home
um uh they they were starting to flirt
with one another he goes out and gets
them and they had they had sex with one
another he goes out to get some more
beer uh when he comes back uh she
decides that she's been raped I mean it
was not a good you know story for a rape
conviction the night before she was to
go on the stand the assistant district
attorney hypnotized her and her story
got better
that's a textbook case of how not to use
him using it to just suggest to people
things not to help them recover things
and so that's a precedent that's a
presence people versus Shirley right so
California now the law is that if a
witness or victim has been hypnotized
they may not testify now I frankly think
that's too Draconian because you know if
somebody threatens to kill your family
if you testify that will influence what
you say but those people can testify if
somebody's a known liar has lied 15
times like certain prominent politicians
we know
um they can testify but someone's been
you know somebody's dangle a watch in
front of them they can't I've testified
in a couple of appeals cases in Texas uh
in which Witnesses of uh accessories to
murder or are of you know somebody
outside a house just before somebody was
murdered you know she was across the
street looking in we're hypnotized and
what I found in cases like that is they
don't change their story very much and
they don't change their conviction all
that much and the fact facts tend to
support them and I said look
you know it could have contaminated the
witness but I don't think it did and in
most of those cases we've sustained the
convictions so it's a difficult area but
and where where it's problematic rich is
that sometimes police get lazy they say
well we don't need to do the Dirty Work
of you know getting you know concrete
evidence we'll just get somebody
hypnotized and that'll take care of it
and that's not good right and I I
suppose the fear would also be that if
you had a witness who is highly
hypnotizable and you had a clinical
hypnotist with an agenda trying to drive
a certain result that that person could
push that witness in a certain direction
to derive a result that's absolutely
right and and the California legislature
passed a law that said there were
circumstances under which a hypnotized
victim or witness May testify and that's
if it's done by an independent licensed
professional so it's not a member of the
police or the uh District Attorney's
office if you video record everything
that's happened including knowing what
the hypnotist knew before
um they they conducted the interrogation
um that those people may testify if it's
done properly interesting
um I want to talk about perhaps my
favorite use case which is high
performance States I know that you
worked at some point with the Stanford
women's swimming team so I want to hear
a little bit about that and have a
discussion around kind of enhancing our
ability to perform under duress yes sure
and I know you're you're good at that
stuff so you can tell me what your
perspective on it is uh Richard quick
who is the coach of the Stanford women's
swimming team which is a very good team
has been he's one of the all-time greats
yeah Richard he passed away but yeah
yeah yeah
um uh he he called me up and he said
look I got a problem
um my swimmers are swimming better in
practice than they are in Meats their
times are better and that tells me that
there's some kind of competitive anxiety
that's interfering with their
performance so what I did was I got
together with him and I had them
go into a state of hypnosis and imagine
swimming your best race you know just
doing and you're a swimmer so you know
what that's like but the interesting
thing about swimming unlike other sports
is it's not a contact sport in a sense
it doesn't really matter what the person
in the next Lane is doing what matters
is what you're doing and they got
distracted by it they were not so they
got out of touch with their body they
got out of touch with how they could in
fact enact their best strategy to
perform at their best and from what I
heard they were they were doing better
that it helped them refocus on their
relationship with their body and their
swimming plan not on whatever the girl
on the next Lane was doing so did you do
that like you performed uh hypnosis in a
group setting for them yeah I did how
many times did you do that uh I don't
remember I think two or three not a
whole lot but they said I taught them to
do it for themselves right so yeah and
we're going to get into self-hypnosis in
a bit but just to kind of stay on this
for a little bit what's interesting
about this
foreign
the difference between doing this
through the modality of hypnosis versus
what we would consider to be
visualization like I I kind of learned a
version of this in high school as a
swimmer like you lay down you know and
for 10 or 15 minutes you just visualize
every piece of the race going you know
in in the minutest detail slowing down
time so that you can anticipate
everything so how is that different
qualitatively from uh inducing a
hypnotic state to do the same thing
essentially to be honest with you I
don't think it's all that different I
think if you're hypnotizable that kind
of relaxed visualization
excuse me is a kind of hypnotic
experience
sorry I'm inside
um
it um because what you're doing is first
of all dissociating your imagery about a
very vigorous physical activity from
your current physical state right so
you're you're dissociating the content
from the physical experience of it
and you're picturing and I like the sort
of time Distortion and other things you
did to kind of allow yourself to to
micromanage what you would be doing and
um so to be honest with you I don't
think there's a whole lot of difference
between that kind of
relaxed imagery that you were doing and
hypnosis if you're hypnotizable and what
is the relationship between what you
just described and and what would be
considered like a quote unquote Flow
State like talk about marketing they you
know who I don't know who came up with
the the term Flow State but chick sent
me high yeah it's a that's a genius
because people love that right it's not
a new idea but it's been kind of
um
uh encapsulated in a notion that's very
modern and appealing yeah he did and you
know I read the book I like I've heard
him talk I I like what he says
um he has there are a couple things that
are a little different he calls the flow
state autotelic that is you you just
being in it is enough to make you feel
good so it's not just what you do with
it but just being there
and there's a sense in which that's a
component of mindfulness too that you
just you know get to a point where you
allow yourself to experience things
non-judgmentally and you just feel good
because you're doing it not because
you're doing anything in particular with
it
um
and he he he talks about absorption so
that you're totally engaged in what
you're doing you're not worried about
consequences or outcomes you're just in
the experience which shares something
with meditation too and but it is true
that in hypnosis particularly if you're
moderately to highly hypnotizable you do
have this sense of just
going along with things and enjoying the
ride you know you're just letting it
happen but you're in control of what's
happening I mean that's where people
worry about loss of control but you're
really enjoying it and controlling it we
tend to use hypnosis more to sort of
problem solve and flow is meant to be
about you know getting engaged in work
or pleasurable like experiential
experiential yeah
um so they're they're related but
they're not exactly the same thing
in my experience as an endurance athlete
uh when I was you know really training
hard for some of these crazy long races
there would be days where I would
literally be out all day like I'd be on
my bike for eight or nine hours and the
fitter that I got
um my relationship with time would
change like I would build up to a place
where that type of activity didn't seem
to be that daunting and didn't seem like
it took all day like there was this
relationship with time that was very
different and I don't know whether
it's because of
the manner in which breath Works in an
elevated kind of aerobic
heart rate zone of activity but my
experience was that of of a hypnotic
State like you could call it a flow
state but to me it did feel more
hypnotic because of that timepiece there
and I'm interested
as to whether you've thought a little
bit about or whether you've done any
work around like endurance activity or
physical activity in general and the
extent to which that alters your brain
State and whether or not that could be
considered hypnotic oh I absolutely
think it could be considered hypnotic
but I'm interested in your language
you're very accomplished at these
extreme athletic performances but you're
still I hear you sort of describing it
as though it were I finally got my body
to the point where it let me do this
where it let me have be able to compress
time and see it in another way and I
would I'm a psychiatrist this is the
clinical psychiatrist coming out I know
I love it it's free no no choice
um that your brain got to the point
where it allowed your body to do what it
was doing interesting and you were
focusing more on you got to the point
and this is where your body lets you do
it but you got to the point where even
though your body was forming at very
high and unusual levels
you were able to experience the sort of
accomplishment and pleasure of your body
in this new kind of motion rather than
your body got to the point where you
could enjoy it right the relationship
with the discomfort changed and that
that that state changed in the brain
that's not in the body yes yes that's
what I would so but what do you think
about that I'd be interested in your I
mean I think that's that's super
interesting of course there's the
physical capacity to do the work sure
but it's your relationship with that
work are you dreading it are you
enjoying it are you in a in a kind of
relaxed State while you're doing it
that's all signaling that's occurring
you know between the two ears right
right exactly and you know part of it's
I mean I'm not saying your body had
nothing to do with it had plenty to do
with it and your body was by that time
well enough trained that you it could
allow you to think about what was
happening in a different way and not
just feeling in pain and I can't do this
and I'm out of breath you know you you
so you got to a point where you could
begin to develop the way your brain
managed this transformed body and but it
was partly your brain was you know our
brains grow and reconfigure every night
when we when we go to sleep we you know
cut off certain synapses and add others
and so our brains change too and so I'm
guessing that your your body was in
training but so is your brain yeah well
I would I would characterize it as being
a heightened state of absorption being
very absorbed in the activity but
perhaps not necessarily disassociated so
I mean maybe this is semantics and it
gets into a a conversation around the
differences between
hypnosis Flow State and and also
something I want to talk about which is
mindfulness okay being present with the
state that you're in sure and that's
that's different I've heard you
characterize the differences being that
mindfulness is a practice whereas
hypnosis is a tool to solve a problem so
talk a little bit about that yes yeah I
think it is and I I think
um
uh partly you got to a point where it
was very difficult but it wasn't a
struggle you know you weren't worried
that your body was going to let you down
you're going to get hurt
um uh but you also
um could kind of you know be the
conductor of the symphony not you know
and you knew that the players were able
to play their pieces properly so it was
I it it allowed you to have a certain
level of comfort and then impose that
level of comfort on your body so it
became coordinated not a struggle you're
you know you knew your the parts of your
body could do what they had to do and
you're like and I I've talked to concert
pianists who said when I'm if if I
actually start thinking well I'm playing
about what which finger is going to do
what I'm screwed of course right I said
so I'm thinking about the tone and the
pacing and a lot of and the you know the
emotion going along with it that's what
I'm thinking about so you've got to have
a well-oiled machine that lets you do
that you have to be experienced enough
with it but you also have to in your
brain be in that role of
managing it at that level right you know
it's not a little struggle it's not you
know the first time you're out training
it's uh kind of coordinating the
symphony in your body
um mindfulness
um I think is meant to be
there's less focus on control and more
on sort of lack of control you know just
the way you experience emotion is you
don't fight it and I think this is a
good idea you just let the emotions flow
like a storm blowing by and see what
happens because very often we create
more trouble by fighting negative
feelings than by just having them saying
Oh yeah now how do I put that in
perspective and so I do think that
mindfulness is meant to be more of a way
of being you do this sort of body scan
where you check out different parts of
your body and how they're feeling and
cultivating compassion which is an
important part of mindfulness that you
try to think about situations or people
who may irritate you or make you angry
or something and develop compassion for
them and that's a very important
practice too that in in hypnosis that's
not you know a major feature although
your openness to accepting new input
from the hypnotist is a kind of
compassion for them you're saying I know
this isn't me and I'm going to trust
that he or she is doing something that
will help me not hurt me yeah it does it
does feel like there is some shared DNA
there uh and and and there is a sense
that mindfulness can be used as a tool
to solve a problem I mean I had Judd
Brewer in here I know that you know him
and he's got a whole thing about
mindfulness in the context of of habit
formation smoking cessation he's got his
own app for that and it seems like it
could be applied towards the same ends
that hypnosis can be but you're getting
there through different routes well yes
I think that's true Judd Brewer's study
is the one I talked about mindfulness
turning down activity in the posterior
cingulate cortex that's his work it's
very good work
um I think you know mindfulness is
Eastern and hypnosis is Western that is
you know it's not meant to be there to
do to accomplish something to solve a
problem that's kind of an unmindful
thing to do it's meant to just be an
experience that will help you and you
know in the Buddhist thinking detach
from this sort of transitory connection
to a Persona that we have from time to
time that's the way the Buddhists think
about it uh whereas hypnosis is very
much this is you this is your life this
is what you got this is your body figure
out how to use it as well as you can and
it's more you know problem oriented
you're right it's it do it for a purpose
which is a typical Western way to
approach things whereas the Eastern
people would say that's your problem
yeah you've got to let go of it yeah
it's really a philosophical distinction
yes it is and but it means a respect for
different traditions and and you know
I'm very impressed and glad that
mindfulness has has achieved so much
attention and popularity in this country
we associate uh hypnosis uh with you
know the idea that you need a guide and
certainly a guide is important but
um we do have the capacity to induce
this state ourselves so let's talk about
self-hypnosis and maybe we can do that
in the context of reverie or app and and
how we should be thinking about how we
can incorporate this into our own lives
thanks well that's what I hope to do you
know I began to realize uh rich and I
think that you know there were things I
I think unfortunately the pandemic has
forced us into this you know we have to
we we used to think that doing good
Psychotherapy is all about
um you know person to person you know
looking at one another across the room
and having feelings and correcting
distortions and I do that I think it's
important but I I think there are
elements of various psychotherapies that
are much more disseminable than we than
we think and that's what we're that's
the challenge now and I thought you know
I've used hypnosis with about 7 000
people in my career that's a lot of
people but I've learned things that I'm
convinced can help a lot more people
than that and I want sort of my legacy
to be to spread the wealth to help
people get what they can even if they're
not sitting in the office with me and so
we designed reverie to be interactive
um so that it's not simply listened to a
recording and do something but rather I
suggest you do something I ask you know
are you is your left hand feeling
lighter than your right or not they give
an answer we analyze it with AI and then
they get a different suggestion based on
what they just told that's interesting
so it is it it changes each person's
experience is different depending on how
they responded to us and so I tried to
make it as much like what happens in my
office as I could but also share the
strategies you know focus on what you're
for now what you're against recognize
your ability to transform perception and
make your body comfortable and so the
the apps are each about 12 to 15 minutes
long interactive we ask you to rate
before and after how your level of
stress is or your level of pain is we're
getting a 35 reduction in stress in the
first 15 minutes after people do that
and we're getting a 25 reduction in pain
um we get one out of five people stop
smoking so people and people can tell
right away I mean what I really am happy
about is they'll know is this helping me
or not if it is good keep doing it if
it's not maybe try some more but if you
don't want to that's fine too so and we
have some hypnotic minutes too we have
some things where people
um uh just take a minute or two to
reinforce what they've learned before
and a minute isn't too long to do that
and we're finding that like 40 of people
with the hypnotic minutes feel better
just after a minute of re-engaging in
that state you know and we we find you
mentioned earlier that you know people
um if they just have a memory or a smell
or a sound of something an old song or
something it changes their mental state
and they kind of get back in that mode
and that's what we're finding with
reverie too that people can just dip
back into the experience and get a lot
of the benefit from it very quickly so I
hope it will help spread the wealth help
people
learn from it try it out see what it
feels like and uh and hopefully feel
better yeah the that's fascinating and
and and quite a service so I I commend
you for that
um and you know and you describing that
I can't help but think about the
induction phase we talked a bit a bit
about like breath work and how that can
help induce the state but I also assume
that the choice of words is very
important and there's a lot of Science
and and your experience that's gone into
we say this at this point and now we say
this so talk a little bit about like how
you make those choices and how that you
know what that's doing to our brains and
our bodies to kind of create the the
preferred receptivity sure well I try to
make the language simple clear I want
people to feel when they're going into
their State feel what they're doing when
they're in it and feel what it means to
come out of it so I want to be clear
about that
I want to use language that
um
focuses more on what people are for than
what they're against that tends to stir
engagement rather than rejection or a
sense of failure I want people to have
an experience that allows them to get
the best of whatever their ability is
and see how they how they respond to it
so
I I try to be
positive clear simple and
straightforward about about the way I
tell people what to do and I think in
the hypnosis there has been a lot of
sort of mystification of what you have
to say and how long it has to take you
know I used to be taught early on you
have to take 20 25 minutes to get people
counting upstairs and downstairs and all
kinds of stuff
and my I myself wouldn't want to devote
that much time to that you know and it's
not necessary so the other thing is I
try to make it fairly rapid and
efficient you know you do it here if
you've got the ability do it see what it
feels like and then come out of it and
be clear with yourself when you're doing
it and when you've stopped right and if
you're somebody who has a a low
receptivity to hypnosis can you get a
refund like if you're just somebody who
can't be hypnotized and you're like this
is not working for me listen this caused
so little again with it we and by the
way the the app can be downloaded from
the App Store reveri uh
we're building it it's an IOS app now
we're building an Android app and then
you can send to our website
www.rivery.com a request that you'll be
notified when the Android app is up and
running it isn't yet
um
so
um we try to use it in a way that makes
it accessible to people but also we
accept and they accept if it's helping
them good if it's not do something else
that's fine and and the one other thing
I'd mention is the book I wrote with my
father was called trans and treatment
clinical users of hypnosis and the idea
is that they're related but they're
separate things so
what you do people because when people
are in a trance they concentrate
intently they reduce their critical
judgment
um you want to be sure that the
therapeutic strategy you're using is
pretty good uh you don't want
um you know to suggest to them something
in that receptive attentive state that
maybe is a bad idea to begin with and so
I would say that even for some people
who aren't hypnotizable at all they can
benefit from the strategy from the way
we're approaching the problem and and so
there are some people who aren't
advertisable but if you just sit there
and listen to me for a few minutes you
may take on a new point of view about
how to deal with an old problem so
rather than fighting food you eat with
respect for your body
you focus on feeding your body the way
you would feed your baby or your dog or
cat you know put in it what's good for
it and that makes you feel good about it
you can eat like a gourmet you can eat
less but enjoy eating more that seems
paradoxical but it really isn't you know
most of the time when we were watching
television or playing with our phone or
something I had a a friend who who
started the reverie app he said he uh he
felt terrible when he looked at a
picture of a party and somebody was
wearing the same shirt he was only he
had this huge belly and he said I
realized it was me you know yeah so he
started he'd use the app he started
eating with respect he lost 40 pounds
he's now walking to work from Palo Alto
to Mountain View and back he doesn't
ride in a car anymore and he's kept the
weight off and he's going around
proselytizing about it now and he he
wasn't that hypnotizable but the
approach was something that appealed to
him cognitively and he's using it
cognitively and changing a whole bunch
of aspects of his behavior yeah reverie
reverence self-reverence I like that um
you know I can't help but think about uh
the similarities between that notion of
self-care self-love and loving-kindness
meditation right like you're you're
you're practicing a form of meditation
that is is is sort of thinking about or
or or wishing for or or practicing
loving kindness towards others but also
towards yourself right with reverence I
I love that connection with reverence I
hadn't thought of it but I believe me oh
really so where does the name come from
assume that it's more revery like a
dream oh I got you yes
well here you have the double on top
yeah I like it
um but you know I think
um the difference is that in mindfulness
you learn to be compassionate for
yourself
through contemplating compassion for
others and with the technique we use in
hypnosis is having compassion for
yourself and for your own body and
thinking of your body the way you would
think of some other trusting innocent
creature that depends upon you and so it
is more you know if you think about it
Eastern cultures are more sociocentric
that you know they are their social
environment you know they they don't
separate themselves in the same way that
we do here we're Splendid individuals
you know and freedom is everything God
forbid you should wear a mask you know
um and and that's not I mean people were
wearing masks in Japan you know 10 years
before it was covet so
um I do think they reflect cultural
differences that that in in eastern
cultures having a they don't value
individually the individuality in the
same way we do but B
um it is more natural to cultivate
compassion for your community for people
around you here it's more natural to
cultivate compassion for yourself for
individuals and so you learn to be more
compassionate to yourself and to your
body with hypnosis but uh so it's the
the the notion of compassion is very
important but it's sort of implemented
in a different way that is I think
culturally appropriate yeah yeah that
that cultural distinction I mean the
idea that you know we would never treat
we would never treat other people the
way that we treat ourselves right is
right you know there's something kind of
inherently American about that I think
you're right I'm afraid I have to
confess yes that's true
um I want to talk a little bit about uh
your lab I mean in addition to being a
clinic a clinician you're also a
researcher right you referenced some of
the work that you're doing with huberman
lab around breath
um what are what are some of the other
studies that you're involved in right
now and and also like what are what are
some of the studies that you you you
wish to see performed that would
um give us a lot more clarity and kind
of uh uh you know help with a mass
adoption of this modality well uh there
are a couple of things we're we are
doing some studies on the effects of the
reverie app
um because we need to provide an
Evidence base sure you're getting all
these data sets works that's right I
mean we have one study of 15 900 people
showing a reduction of uh you know 35 in
stress in the first 15 minutes that's
you know and we're doing more of that we
need to do studies with control
conditions which were always hard to
come up with but we'll find a way so I
want to do more studies on what the
actual effect of using reverie is
compared with other things like
meditation we're comparing meditation
and breath work with Andrew and uh
finding some very interesting things
that breath work in very short pieces of
breath work like five minutes a day for
a month are having pretty big effects on
people's anxiety and stress and sleep as
well so that's one thing we're doing I'm
collaborating
um with a wonderful young colleague at
Stanford Nolan Williams who's doing
transcranial magnetic stimulation and so
we're actually he loved the idea of
taking on the challenge can we change a
fixed neural trait like hypnotizability
and so we're using TMS he was just on
the Today Show the other day showing how
is using it for depression and suicidal
thinking actually very effectively
what's TMS I'm sorry transcranial
magnetic stimulation got it so you know
hypnosis with animal magnetism 250 years
ago this is real magnetism applied
locally to the brain and if you know you
know that electric current when it flows
through a wire or a nerve generates a
magnetic field around it that
circumvents circles the wire in the
perpendicular Direction
um conversely a magnetic field induces
changes in the electrical current in the
neuron and so you can activate or
inhibit a brain region very precisely
using these transcranial magnetic
stimulators and he's been very effective
in treating depression I've seen
patients say I feel like my old self
after two years not that I feel better I
feel like my own that's super
interesting and and we're stimulating
the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex and
we've got some preliminary evidence that
we can enhance hypnotizability at least
transiently wow so it's the first time
we've been able to change a neural trait
and the idea is we've been studying it
with fibromyalgia we've got support from
the national Center for complementary
and Integrative Health and we're hoping
that it could be an augmentation to a
hypnotic treatment for fibromyalgia and
other kinds of treatment resistant pain
so we're exploring that both to
understand better the the brain
mechanism but also as a potential new
treatment uh for that wow that's amazing
and and I like the kind of connective
tissue dating all the way back back to
Mesmer right like Mesmer almost had it
right oh he just you know he's a little
bit off on part of it a little fluid
thing but like here we are that's right
a little ahead of his time but not in a
way that always helped um in addition to
reverie if somebody is is inspired or
intrigued by everything that that you've
shared today and thank you for that uh
how does one go about finding a you know
an appropriate clinical hypnotist so
they're not you know falling under the
prey of some stage hypnotist if they
want to explore this right we'll stay
out of theaters but the the I would say
the the important thing is
um to find somebody who is trained and
licensed in a clinical discipline so
clinical psychologist physician dentist
uh social worker with marriage and
family counseling credentials
um find someone whose primary thing is
that they're a trained clinician and who
also was trained in hypnosis there are
uh there's two good professionals
assigned three good professional
societies the society for clinical and
experimental hypnosis you can look up
sceh.us the American Society for
clinical hypnosis uh uh as
ch.net I think and there's a division 31
of the American Psychological
Association they're all licensed and
trained psychologists who use hypnosis
so your primary search should be for a
good licensed and trained professional
and then someone who knows something
about hypnosis and there are now
websites that can help you identify
those people Psychology today has one
and others who can help you find someone
who has and you'll see what kind of
Professional Training they have yeah
that's great we'll put those links up in
the show notes of course and before I
let you go I was remiss in not asking
you about
the work that you've done with breast
cancer patients I mean cancer is really
you know that was that was you know
really has been I don't know if it still
is but initially was a big part of your
focus right that's right so I you know I
wanted to give you the opportunity to
talk a little bit about that because I
think that's that's really powerful well
thank you when I when I came to Stanford
um I was recruited in part by Europe
yallum who is you know the leading
figure in group Psychotherapy and who
was working on a book on existential
Psychotherapy and he said to me
you know the existential philosophers
have read written that you don't really
live authentically until you face the
possibility of non-being and if that's
true
um then perhaps a period of facing your
death could be a period of growth so you
know that maybe we've been approaching
this from the wrong way just make them
less anxious and depressed but help them
grow
and
um uh he said would you like to co-lead
a group with me so this is like my first
year as an assistant professor and the
world's Authority in group therapy says
would you co-lead a group you think for
a second and you say yes so I did and I
love this group you know these women
were dealing with very difficult things
but they weren't getting demoralized you
know they were getting remoralized they
would grieve when somebody from the
group died and we were warned by some
oncologists that you know you demoralize
them because you know the the two years
arrival was 50 they were going to see
other people die as though cancer
patients you know don't understand that
they could die from their kids the first
thing everybody thinks half of all
people diagnosed with cancer live to die
of something else more women with breast
cancer die of heart disease than breast
cancer so you know it's it's not a great
thing but you know uh people can deal
with it and I was so impressed
at how women faced their own mortality
but differently by seeing it in someone
else you know you can see things in
somebody else that you're going through
but you can't see for yourself
we had one woman who came in and said
you know I think it's time for me to
sort of hasten my exit you know she was
talking about assisted suicide because
my husband's a banker but he's not a
teller he doesn't talk and I think he's
had it with me it's just too much now
his husband wasn't in the room and one
of the rules of says is you know here
and now in the room so I said I wonder
if she's asking us a question are we
tired of her are we wishing she weren't
here and she just got you know covered
with praise she was always beautifully
dressed even though she was clearly very
sick she was getting closer to death
matched accessories make up everything
and they admired how well she looked
after herself in her body even though
she was that sick so they they made it
clear to her they wanted her to live as
long as possible and she did not shorten
her life she died about four months
later
and in her will it was written that they
sent a bus to take us all from the
building where the group met to her
memorial service wow and another woman
in the group said you know looking being
in this group is like looking into the
Grand Canyon when you're afraid of
heights you know if you fell down it'd
be a disaster but you feel better about
yourself because you're able to look I
can't say I feel Serene but I can look
at it and um it was very touching to
hear her say that and to recognize that
that's what was going on that they were
feeling like experts in living and
experts in dealing with the disease they
felt better about themselves because
they could help other people you know we
do that in medicine all the time when I
was training at Boston City Hospital and
learning to do lumbar punctures and
things are what we used to joke with one
another is it's C1 screw one do one
teach one you know that that's the
progression you feel better about
yourself because you've learned
something you can use to help someone
else and that's what they were learning
and that's what they were doing so we
found at the end of a year in this
random trial that the women in our
weekly support groups that ended with
self-hypnosis by the way we taught them
to grieve losses to picture the loss of
someone who died and at the same time
picture on the other side of the screen
one thing she left with you that's still
within you and and they were half as
anxious and depressed by the end of the
year as the control group they had half
the pain the control group from doing
the self-hypnosis exercises on very low
amounts of medication and the big
surprise was that I got the idea because
people were talking about wishing while
your cancer and we weren't wishing it
away at all we were saying you've got to
deal with it
um that they lived 18 months longer on
average than the control and we have
replicated we tried to replicate that
study at a time when the hormonal
treatments got to be a lot better than
they were originally we found that women
with non-hormonally responsive cancer
lived longer in the treatment group but
overall we did not replicate that but
we've seen we've done our meta-analysis
recently of all the studies on
Psychotherapy and survival and find a
significant survival advantage for
cancer patients randomized to various
kinds of supportive Psychotherapy and
there's one published in the New England
Journal recently with dying patients
patients entering palliative care with
lung cancer who live four months longer
if they got this palliative care support
facing their death than if they didn't
so you know and we know married cancer
patients overall live four months longer
than unmarried cancer patients yeah
what's interesting about that for me and
it goes back to what we were talking
about earlier about trauma and and
volition like the the kind of welcoming
into the experience a level of
acceptance and that this idea that you
know we think that if we if we deny it
or we pretend it doesn't exist or we
ignore it that that will reduce our
anxiety but in truth it's quite the
opposite right like in in kind of
embracing the you know the the harsh
reality of the circumstances ends up
reducing the anxiety because you're you
learn to be in a in a place of
cohabitation with it I guess right you
can face it the devil you know is better
than the devil you don't know you know
at least you can see aspects of it and
put it into perspective uh there have
been some interesting recent studies of
people dying of cancer taking psilocybin
in the couple of psychotherapy and it
kind of surprises me to tell you the
truth you know I wouldn't want to have a
bad trip when I was you know facing
immunity and the majority of them and
they get careful Psychotherapy as well
during this report I could just see it
from a different point of view and it
helped me feel that my capacity to live
to experience things was so precious and
I still have it and I'm going to lose it
but I still have it and they found it
reassuring so I think you're absolutely
right that having the strength and
ability to face it
strengthens you it doesn't weaken you um
I wonder if there is a
is there is there a sense of
enhanced receptivity to hypnosis uh when
somebody has undergone some kind of
psychedelic experience and we I don't
want to do a whole podcast on
psychedelics we're rounding this out now
and that's a whole other discussion but
I know there's a lot of emerging science
here and and some interesting things
that are happening there is and there's
more interest in we're building a
program at Stanford to do it and there
are a number of other excellent places
that have programs and they're taking it
seriously I think there is one message
though that is pretty strong and that is
that changing mental states can in and
of itself be therapeutic you see things
from a different point of view you know
you make the mistake of reading your
email at 11 o'clock at night and you get
some nasty email and they think oh God
what am I going to do and the next
morning after a night of sleep you say
oh that like him again you know I'll
deal with that
um just being able to see the same
problem from a different mental
perspective in and of itself helps
enhance your coping ability which is
what hypnosis is and and which is what a
psychedelic experience induces Bingo and
and sleep too you know absolutely same
thing so I mean we can't live without
sleep so we our brains are constructed
to experience different states of
Consciousness and there's a reason for
it it helps us it helps us deal with
stress it doesn't it's not a problem
it's a potential solution yeah well
it'll be interesting to see uh to kind
of pay attention to the research that's
it's interesting that Stanford's doing
that now I mean I know Johns Hopkins is
associated with that that's right you
know this is now becoming more
mainstream it is yeah well I hope
hypnosis will too yeah so on that note
as we kind of end this thing
um you know leave us with some parting
thoughts about
uh hypnosis self-hypnosis for the person
who's listening or watching who's
interested in this
um what would be a good way for them to
begin or wrap their heads around how
this might benefit their lives well you
know consider the kind of problem you
have and whether it's something you're
you're itching to do something about
um think about situations in your life
already where a change in state of
consciousness has had some beneficial
effects so you may have some experience
already that you could see an old
problem from a new point of view
and then find a way to give it a try you
know it's one of these things where
there really aren't any side effects the
way there are with meds and
um we're just taking a little bit of
time to try out transforming your
experience of a problem might make a
difference and reverie is one there are
other there are many good professionals
who can help you with it there are
things to read as well about hypnosis
there's our book trance and treatment
but there are others too and I think you
sort of put yourself in in experimental
it's a low-cost rapid
experimental experience that could make
a big difference
well I appreciate you coming here to
talk to me uh a lot of respect for the
work that you're doing I think it's
super important and it's been a
privilege to
hear about this world and and learn
about your world so thank you thank you
very much well you've set an example for
personal transformation that a lot of
people have followed and I really
appreciate that yeah through my own
version of self-hypnosis
but anyway
um I'd love to talk to you more and
learn more about this so uh perhaps uh
part two at some point when it works out
for you so thank you thank you all right
peace foreign
[Music]